alisa buchinger karate meisterin 2015
mehr als leistungssportlerin beim
bundesheer
heute habe ich die chance mir
anzuschauen was eine soldatin bei dem
der stress macht
das ist das szenario militärstreife
hätte gelegenheit der fahndung und da
gibt es proteste nach oben in die
wohnung die aufgebaut wurde zu schauen
warum die uniformen der militärstreife
die möglichkeit der civil aus zu fahren
damit sie nicht erkennen weise und in
dem speziellen fall wird geübt
wenn sie an soldaten besetzt wie man
doch vorher
der verein selbst anzeigt wie wiso wie
bringen wir zu boden und der so lernt
man so langsam ist jetzt weiter montreux
care weil jetzt am anfang an lernen und
jetzt habe die möglichkeit dass sie das
eigentlich jeder zeit verlieren kann
ein
aus unserer sonder bekleidungs magazin
verlagert die ganze ausrüstung der
militärstreife was cat oil ist es gibt
ganz viele einzelbestandteile und den
smog buster mal probieren
das
du warst du scheinst ja mittlerweile
schon 15 monate und immer mit der
spezialisierung sondern
diese ausflucht um
was genau macht
die haben einen neuen akku oder
durchgeführt und für das wird die b 80 t
verwendet das training zwar für deswegen
noch blau markiert das arme ausstrecken
die schultern nach oben ziehen und korn
durch klima soll einen länger bieten und
ist im ziel
ziemlich starken trainings toptalent
jeden dort sogar militärstreife und das
ist mein arbeitsplatz erinnern und nach
jeder ausfahrt oder nach jedem einsatz
wird natürlich auch bericht schreiben
warum machst du dir jetzt eigentlich
fürs bundesheer entschieden nicht für
die polizei weil bei der polizei kommen
jahr eigentliche sache machen
ja es war mal angedacht haben wir die
polizei aber mit darf eine
militärstreife beziehungsweise mit der
polizei entschieden weil da die
möglichkeit habe viel mehr sport zu
betreiben und die kam für ausbildung
machen also das spektrum an ausbildungen
dann mit der extrem groß und die
möglichkeit ins ausland zu gehen